now Louie I'm not doing my job if I
don't ask you about the election it's
just a week away you want to talk about
it who are you supporting I'm gonna vote
for Hillary because and it's stupid to
say cuz I'm a performer and so you lit
my audience in half but I I think she's
great
it's not a sight like a lesser of two
evils I think she's great
I really like I think she's really
talented and I think she's super smart
and I think she's done this for I'll
take her over anybody there really isn't
some it's not because of between the two
of them I would take her over any
anybody else who would do it and to me
it's really exciting to have the first
mother in the White House that's what I
think this is not about the first woman
it's about the first mom what is it
about me about a mom because a mother
she's got it a mother just does it she's
got your cheat sheet she feeds you and
teaches you she protects you she takes
care we've had two hundred and forty
years of fathers
yeah father after [ __ ] bald father fat
father every kind of father and fathers
are okay I'm a father
you're a dad yeah we a great father can
give a kid 40% of his needs top tops out
of 40% yes yes any mob to Mister
optimistic any mother I just a mother
like just a not even trying mother 200%
like she can do to like what's the last
conversation you had with your mom was
probably his mom all right yeah it's
enough like they just yeah they just
keep so to me she's like I just it's
exciting to think about I'm excited
about this election because she I don't
want it to be the other guy just get
look if you vote I have no problem
anybody votes for Trump if that's your
ideology you know although four more
years of I don't know if we can do
because this is four more years of a guy
who can't be criticized what's more
important than about a president then
that you can fall over them that's what
presidents are for yeah guys sharks like
that
and the president is to get it drunk and
blame them for everything yes use them
of this guy every time he's criticized
everything stops and he makes everybody
pay yeah that's not how it works we need
somebody who can take abuse yes Hillary
Clinton can take abuse we've been hazing
her we've been holding her down and
spitting in her mouth and yelling at her
and she just gets something goes well I
just think that if children have proper
health care you have you want people yes
really changed my mind that was all in
for trauma you're here but you know what
it's it you are feels a specific need or
it's important to you that people get
out and vote especially there's some
younger people out there Millennials
that say oh I don't know if this is it
was a good choice for me here I don't
know if I'm gonna vote or I'm undecided
what exactly I don't have any any
quarrel with somebody who votes for
Trump if that's what they feel that they
want it but if you don't vote at all
because you just out say if you're like
a liberal who's not going to vote your
piece
this is what they're like I don't really
like her voice robot are you kidding me
grow up I just don't something your back
we know I don't want somebody who's
likable or cool anymore we need up just
a we need a two-faced conniving just I
got a million schemes a boy way all her
is out there yeah every email she ever
wrote is in the newspapers and she's not
in jail which is amazing but just we
needs just a tough [ __ ] mother so this
is my feeling overall I think if you
vote for Hillary you're a grown-up
yeah if you vote for Trump you're a
sucker right if you don't vote for
anybody you're an [ __ ]
nicely
you